welcome back
joining us now to talk about coronavirus
recovery
all the latest news the senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell from capitol hill
senator thanks for being here yeah good
evening
you spent some time on the on the senate
floor today lambasting the house
speaker's efforts on this latest three
trillion dollar bill and what's inside
it
i wanted to ask you about the messaging
that you're sending about pumping the
brakes
on a phase four as of yet you had the
fed
chair powell say that this is a
financial situation without modern
precedent
additional fiscal support could be
costly but worth it
if it helps avoid long-term damage and
leaves us with a stronger recovery
essentially saying lawmakers may need to
do more
how do you reconcile those two things
easily
i think the chairman of the fed is
correct and we do anticipate
having to act again at some point i do
think though
in terms of timing the chairman of the
fed didn't
say how quickly and we need to verify
how we've done so far make sure we
know whatever mistakes we've made we
don't want to repeat
so i'm certainly not ruling out another
fiscal package
and i would say the chairman of the fed
and i and the administration are not
necessarily in different places
you called the speaker's efforts just a
political marker
why not take that as the first in a
first serve
and and volley back and forth as you all
have done before
well it's an 1800 page uh liberal
wish list it strikes me it's hardly
salvageable just to give you an example
of some of the
absurdity there's money in there for
illegal immigrants
it mentions the word cannabis of all
things 68 times
more than the word jobs or higher
or mentioned in the entire bill
uh it's a parade of absurdities
that can hardly be taken seriously let
me tell you what i will predict brett
brett i think the president and senate
republican
majorities will be on the same page
when we get to the point where we need
to do another bill
and our red line is going to be
liability protections
for those who are brave enough to begin
to open up the economy again
in the wake of the trial lawyers who are
descending already on hospitals and
doctors and businesses
as of about a week and a half ago 771
lawsuits had already been filed
so we're working on a narrowly crafted
protection
from liability for things directly
related
to the coronavirus and that will have to
be a part
of any package because if we're really
going to get the economy up and going
again people have to be brave enough to
begin to engage in
in economic activity how about the
presence of universities
are they willing to open up for the fall
or are we going to have another period
of time where not only k through 12
students but potentially college
students are still at home
all of those questions need to be
answered by the fall
liability protection will help provide
the answer what triggers that
negotiation start i mean the ppp the
next tranche is going to be up
at some point what will trigger the
action
of legislation yeah well as i said the
president
and senate republicans are going to be
in the same place
we will let you know when we think the
time is right
to begin to move again i think there's a
high likelihood we'll do another bill
and i've just indicated what will need
to be a part of any bill that actually
gets a presidential signature and is
brought up
and passed by a republican majority in
the senate
you said wait to get word but is word
soon
look i think we're all talking about
this i talked to the secretary of the
treasury
about it yesterday to the president's
chief of staff and to the president
recently
about this i think we all believe
that another bill probably is going to
be necessary but i'm not prepared
today to put a precise date on when that
will be
what i can tell you is i told you
earlier that it's going to include
liability protections in order to get
through the senate and in order to be
signed by the president
and we'll look at what the conditions
are in the near future and decide how
that ought to be crafted
but it's not going to be a three
trillion dollar
left-wing wish list like the speaker is
apparently going to try to jam down the
throats of her majority
either later this week or early next
week you mentioned schools
you think the university of louisville
should open up this fall
i want them to feel comfortable to be
able to open up this fall
and i think answering this liability
question is a big part of that
look we the country is yearning to begin
to get back to normal we want to do it
consistent with
phase one and two of the coronavirus
task force at the administration set up
the white house task force
more and more people believe that we can
begin to safely engage again
practicing social distancing wearing a
mask which i had on
until i stood here in front of the
camera we're doing that in the senate
we're up and running we've been in
session the last two weeks i'm not sure
where the house is but they're not here
did you get different medical advice
than the house did
we ask the capital physician how we
could
safely uh re-engage we took his advice
and we're practicing it we're following
the advice we've been given
have you been tested i visited the white
house last
week and the answer to that is yes dr
bright
is up testifying in the house today
saying that the administration was
woefully prepared
says it's still not prepared those plans
have been in place and it's
disappointing they were not pulled out
in january of this year
and followed they were not put on the
table
with a strong leader indicating these
are our plans
everyone fall in line and follow through
with this plan
you said that the previous
administration didn't leave a plan
they push back against that i was wrong
they did leave behind a plan
so i clearly made a mistake in that
regard
as to whether or not the plan was
followed and who's the critic and all
the rest
i don't have any observation about that
because i don't know enough
about the details of that bret to
comment on it
in any detail senator burr pulled
himself off the chairmanship of the
intelligence committee today there's an
investigation fbi investigation dianne
feinstein senator from california
also being investigated for what her
husband did with stocks
your thoughts on that and have you made
a decision about replacing senator burr
as chair of that committee
well chairman burn i had a chance to
talk about that this morning i think he
did the right thing
for the committee and for our republican
conference
i thank him for doing that and at some
point obviously
i'll be naming a new chair
senator rubio senator risch
i'll be naming a new chair sometime soon
okay let me get your thoughts on the
michael flynn situation and the news
about this unmasking what do you make of
it and is it important in your mind
well if there were in fact misbehavior
surrounding the flynn case the american
public
needs to know and clearly that
was the view of the attorney general
i gather it's now in a rather unusual
procedure being
reviewed by the district judge
before whom the case was
i think we're just anxious to get the
facts what actually happened
the american public needs to know all of
us would like
to know and one thing about washington
you guys are so good at your
your job the truth always comes out
sometimes it takes a little longer than
other times but we'll find out
what in fact did happen i want to ask
you about the election you've called it
a challenging environment if a
scale of one to ten ten being the most
confident
where do you think republicans are at
holding the senate well
i'm i'm never totally confident in any
race but i can say
with regard to this question i've said
the same thing from the beginning of
this cycle
to right now excuse me
we have 23 members up we have a really
big class and the reason we have a
really big class is this is the class
that took our majority back in 2014 so
we have a lot of people up
23 up the democrats only have 12. this
was a challenging cycle from the
beginning
to the middle to now and i think the
majority in the senate is very much in
question as it has been
for a year and a half are you trying to
get secretary of state pompeo to run in
kansas
that's been my hope you can see how well
i've done so far
are you still hopeful on that front well
the filing deadline is june 1st so i
guess the suspense won't last much
longer
what do you tell vulnerable vulnerable
republicans in tough races
whether they should be embracing the
president fully
or providing some distance from the
president do you think that this will be
a referendum about how this
administration
handles the health crisis and the
economic crisis
look every state is different and far be
it for me to give advice to a candidate
in montana versus
colorado versus maine i think each of
our candidates are very sharp
they got elected six years ago
they know their state's best and i don't
have any kind of universal
recommendation about how to run in a
given state
you think there'll be an in-person
republican convention
i have no idea that's a very interesting
question
i think that's the current game plan
but i think we have to see what the
status of the pandemic is
in late summer and make the call then
what's your biggest worry right now
right now
in getting the economy open getting this
corona virus
beginning to recede in all parts of the
country
and helping america stage a comeback we
had a
fabulous economy as late as february of
this year
and we'd like for the american people to
begin to benefit from a comeback as soon
as possible look
we can't borrow enough money to prop
this economy up
indefinitely we have to begin to engage
the economy
again i'm convinced brett that we can do
that
safely the president tweeted out that he
thinks
president obama should be called up to a
hearing
in the senate he calls it obama gate
obamacare
it's been going on for a long time it's
been going on from before i even got
elected
and it's a disgrace do you call it that
and what do you think about that
that call to have him testify look
that'll be up to
chairman graham to make those kind of
decisions i think he may have addressed
that already i'm not certain
yeah he said he would be uncomfortable
with it and likely wouldn't happen
where do you think this investigation
goes uh look i'd be up to chairman
graham to determine how to handle this
uh i have a lot of confidence in him and
he knows what he's doing and i'm going
to follow his lead
finally if you're talking to somebody in
kentucky you're up for re-election as
well
what do you tell them this race is about
well in the kentucky race it's a little
different from others
uh what i tell my constituents is i'm
one of four congressional leaders i'm
the only one not from
california or new york and that i'm
mutually uniquely
situated to look out for middle america
and in particular
kentucky so consistent with my
responsibilities as majority leader i
try to do the best i can for kentucky
i think it's been a real benefit to our
state to have
the majority leader of the senate and
really that's the core
argument in my reelection senator
mcconnell we appreciate the time
thank you brett